Let's walk through and pick the Q on which to place Ty, based on the scheduling
policy. Now if you ask the question, what is the minimum I
plus Q for PU for this particular thread Ty, that's
going to be the infinity that Ty has on PU.
The affinity that T, Ty has on Pu is 2. But also we have to look
at the queue size. And the queue size of Pu is 1. There's only one thread
sitting there. So the overall min of I plus Q for Ty with respect to Pu is
3. Let's do the same thing for Ty on Pv. In the case of Pv, its
affinity apparently is higher because there's only one
intervening task that ran since the last time Ty
ran on it. That's good news, but we also have to look at the Q of Pv. When
Ty gets put on Pv's Q, it has to sit behind whatever they may be, and in the
case of Pv, the Q already has four threads to run. So when Ty is put on Pv's
Q, it's going to be stuck at the end of
this Q. Which means that, in a sense, the amount
of intervention that is going to happen for Ty on
Pv, by the time it gets to run, is actually
the size of the, the affinity index for Py with
respect to Pv currently as well as the intervention that's
going to happen by the time it actually gets to
that. So that's four, so the overall I plus Q
is five for this guy, and three for this guy.
Which means that the choice I am going to make
is to put Ty on Pu, because, that's the one that will result in the least
amount of intervention for polluting the cache of
Pu with respect to this particular thread Ty